ce jeudi plusieurs dizaines de salariés
du groupe sanofi rassemblés devant le
ministère de l'économie et des finances
objectif de cette mobilisation protester
contre les suppressions d'emplois
annoncées par la direction
à l'échelle de l'europe ce sont mille
700 emplois qui sont menacés mille en
france dont 400 dans le département
recherche et développement des employés
qui regrette la financiarisation du
secteur avec des objectifs économiques
qui passeraient avant ceux liés à la
santé
ils veulent donc se faire entendre
auprès du gouvernement alors en termes
de formes de financiarisation on est au
delà de la forme maintenant un puisque
sanofi revendique carrément son
appartenance à la finance puisqu'il ils
se gargarisent donc de 26 ans
d'augmentation du dividende
on arrive l'année dernière 4 milliards
de donner aux actionnaires cette année
rebelote 4 milliards et en même temps en
pleine pandémie et ben sanou fils a le
culot de vouloir licencier de dégraisser
donc entre autres sa recherche et son
développement
en attendant sanofi a annoncé des
retards de livraison de son vaccin
contre le coc vite 19
certains employés font directement le
lien entre la réduction des effectifs et
une recherche moins efficace des
salariés en colère soutenu par la gauche
notamment la france insoumise l'échec
sur le vaccin est l'espèce de traduction
de ça quand on divise par deux surnoms
de chercheurs en disant quand on
supprime tous les ans des centres de
recherche mais ça va encore se produire
cet auteur ni strasbourg qui perdent 400
chercheurs qui fut lui qui parte
évidemment on peut pas attendre qu en
créant un tel chaos dans la rolls
cherche ça aboutisse à obtenir un vaccin
assez rapidement certains syndicats ont
été reçus par des conseillers du
ministre de l'économie à la sortie de
cette réunion un constat pessimiste
impossibilité d'agir pour les autorités
car sanofi est une entreprise privée
face à cette forme de fatalisme du
gouvernement les contestataires ont
néanmoins décidé de poursuivre leur
journée de mobilisation ce groupe de
salariés venus de montpellier s'est
rendu ce jeudi après-midi sus devant le
siège de sanofi après des jets d'un fait
de farine
ils ont posé des autocollants sur
l'enceinte ça avant de disperser des
faux billets à l'effigié du patron du
géant pharmaceutique l'eau depuis 2009
on vit des plans sociaux à tire larigot
à l'appât du plus de 80 des projets de
recherche en france on avait un centre
de recherche on est à 3 2 ce qui
explique aussi l'autre n'est qu'au stade
demain pascal bonnefoy a perdu des
postes et en plus comme moi sanofi quand
même première entreprise française du
médicament même pas voulu de trouver un
vaccin moyens d'action qu'on a trouvé
c'est toucher leur image et en fin de
compte on s'est rendu compte que sanofi
ce qu'il dit est ce le plus c'est qu'on
touche à son image de marque donc
déconnade et nouveau patron et tous les
trois-quatre ans ça change
dès qu'on a des nouveaux patrons ont
refait des billets à leurs effigies de
la monnaie qu'on appelle la monnaie sado
fric qui représente exactement la
marchandisation du médicament qui sont
en train de faire dans notre société
face à la multiplication des plans
sociaux dans l'entreprise les employés
promettent de continuer à se battre
d'autres actions sont prévues à l'avenir
notamment sur le site de strasbourg
menacée de fermeture